okay hey everyone it's Mike BOS from
order flows.com here I just want to make
this quick video to show you something
that I thought was interesting today you
know I don't normally trade this last
week the the week between Christmas and
New Year's but you know I do keep my
charts open I do watch the market and
you know there was something that was
very interesting this morning you know
we we rallied up to the highs then we
sold off to the lows made new lows
couple times bounced
up but what I want to talk about today
is these extreme points of control the
point of control right at the top of a
bar now you know I've talked
about stopping volume in previous videos
and usually when you get you know point
of control is the point in the bar the
point of control of the bar the p is the
level in the bar with the most volume
and when you get them on the extremes of
the bars either at the top of a red bar
or the bottom of a green bar it's it's
important you know because it's telling
you that there's volume in the Market
stopping that move and lots of times you
know when you get them at swing highs
and swing lows it could be very telling
as to what the Market's going to do so
let's just take it you know this is
today this is the e- mini this a three
range chart now you know I keep three
range charts open I keep 10 range charts
I keep different charts open you know
depending on on how the day is
progressing you know if it's a fast
moving day I'll look at a 10 range chart
if it's a slow moving day I'll tend to
go to a smaller range chart and you know
honestly you know this is this is the
time where I expect the market to be
pretty quiet and you know comparing a 10
range chart to a three range chart today
or sorry uh well it's the evening time
is but on the 28th um you know this is
the three I'll pull in the 10 range
chart here real
quick uh where are we here so you know
coming into the coming into the the
morning you know 8:00
this was this had been your range so
this is why I'm looking at a three range
chart at this time it's not until you
start coming into the US I mean Europe
is is quiet during this time everybody
takes off the time in Europe even my
programmer he's out in the woods you
know hiking with his family um and a lot
of the European markets are closed so
you know I was expecting the market to
be a bit quiet and it was and it was in
the morning until until things kicked
off in the US so you know you're talking
you know basically a range of 60 and a
half of to 67 which is a pretty tight
range so that's why I was looking at a
three range chart but anyway it digress
um so we're coming into this High here
you know we're making these new highs
just uh you know coming into the cash
open right ahead of the cash open you
hit this High you got a ratio bouns low
you know it's a blue number you do have
a
Divergence you got point of control
right at the top now at this bar right
here you do have a stacked buying
imbalance okay again you know just
because you have a stacked buying
imbalance balance doesn't mean you know
hey get long okay you can take it in
context of the market okay first of all
it's right on the high basically you
know you had the high earlier come off
you get some buying again then you come
up to this level you got point of
control right at the high you know I
said it's right ahead of the cash open
so you know bear that in mind you know
the volume is going to be a bit lighter
you can see how it you know jumps up by
about four times as much after the cash
opens but if you're reading what you
have here you
have you know point of control right at
the top you have some stopping volume up
there you got a ratio which IND this
type of ratio indicates stopping volume
and you know you should be looking for
the market to come off even though you
have this stack buying and balance there
you know just because you can't just go
out and buy every every stack buying and
balance blindly you know watch what's
happening in the market and you know
that's what the order flow is going to
tell you that you know that this stack
buy and balance is probably not going to
work out and what happens right after
you get a stack buy and balance you get
selling IM balances in the opposite
direction you get selling IM balance
selling IM balance so you got a bunch of
things going on up here you know it's
it's like a tempest in a teapot to steal
a quote from Jamie Diamond you have a
Divergence you got a ratio bounds low
you got point of control at the top you
got a couple
imbalances you know that's going to
proceed what you have right here with
the Stacked buying
imbalance and so you know if you're
looking to take this trade you know
where's your your stop going to be you
know it's a three- range chart so you
should be looking to get in in the next
bar so you know somewhere around 66 and
half you know granted you'll be getting
in right on the you know somewhere just
ahead of the cash open but your Stop's
just going to be up here 68 you know so
you're getting in anywhere between 66
and2 67 if you can so 6 and A2 6 and 3/4
7 you know and you're going to have a
stop up here maybe seven and 3/4 eight
at the worst so you know you're risking
basically a point okay and and what
watch you know Watch What
Happens just make this a little bit
easier to
see
so worst case scenario say you missed
this this bar here you get short in this
bar at at six you know probably the
worst possible price in this bar and you
know short at six what happens the
market just sells off boom sells off
right down actually down to the low
makes new lows now is there any sign to
be getting out yet no I mean here you do
have a Divergence with the ratio but you
know these numbers are very very light
and it's a dramatic sell-off you know
that happens pretty quick over the next
couple minutes and often times you know
you get a bounce on thin volume and you
know what that is is you know seven the
selling is lightened up the buying is
not necessarily that strong yet but you
know there is some buying so you know it
it's I'm not necessarily convinced that
it's the time to get out yet okay and
you see the market just continue to go
lower
more selling here you know this is a
three range chart so you got imbalance
imbalance imbalance imbalance you got
you know four imbalances over two bars
it's just split up by this one bar okay
then you get down to this area at you
know at 57 57 and a half you do have a
stack buying in Balance okay you do have
you know your first big
solid uh Delta positive Delta okay and
you're thinking hey maybe I should you
know think it's take some off you can I
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that I'm not going to say oh you
should still hold it but he you come
into this area Deltas get kind of small
you know 300 190 you know some selling
coming in here you got selling a balance
selling imbalance then you do go lower
you got a stack selling IM balance here
and you know I've talked about this
before you know when when I see a stack
buying a balance followed by a stack
selling a balance with in this area you
know my software will will draw out a
Zone um you could adjust it I I have it
set at five cuz really I'm looking for
the Stacked imbalance to hold over the
next five bars if it's you know when
you're trading out in here I'm not
really interested in the Stacked buying
imbalance if I'm going to see a move it
should happen within five bars the next
five bars 1 2 3 4 five but generally the
move should have be starting already by
the third bar and you can see it here
it's not and then you get stacked
imbalance
in the same in that same five bar Zone
you know and I find that to be very
negative so you have the stack buy and
then you get the stack selling in
balance and it's within that zone and
then you just you go lower I mean look
at that you know it's holding you know
and what do you do you trade back up
this area you got 4,000 on the offer up
here you the market can't get past that
and you make new lows okay so you get
down here to 4 and a half 54 a half and
what do you
got point of control right at the bottom
of the bar it's indicating some stopping
volume you have a ratio bounds low and
what happens you know the market Works
its way up it's but this is you know the
first area that it's really stopped and
got some sort of rally you know
here you know it stopped here and what
kind of rally did you get a point not
even you know here at least you're
getting you know two points of
thereabouts um but mostly goes sideways
mostly go so for now it looks like the
stop is or sorry the move lower has been
stopped
and lo and behold here you get another
point of control at the top of this bar
our ratio balance low here indicating
you know again some stopping volume
right here that the market can't right
now can't get past this 57 and what
happens we just go sideways sideways you
got stack buying a balance here didn't
work
out again right after you get that you
get a bearish ratio here again which is
which is not positive for this buying
and balance you know if you're seeing
this buying and balance what you want to
see is a buying ratio not a selling
ratio so it's a indicating prices are
being rejected well you already know
prices are being rejected up here you
know this is just further confirmation
that this is stacked buying and balance
it's probably not going to work
out and you're just going sideways to a
little bit lower you know but you know
really by you know this is at 932 you
know if you're still in this trade if
you're short here and you know you're
holding it until after 10:00 I mean
that's kind of ridiculous I mean you're
trading on a short-term chart a three
range chart and you know if it's just
going sideways you know around your
break even for 30 minutes you it's
probably not going to be a good trade
and it does rally back up and again you
know starts working its way back down
you got selling imbalance here selling
imbalance here the Delta surge kicking
off and you just go
lower uh I
think where where was our low you know
we're going lower lower lower I don't
want to give you an exact replay of the
entire day but
um uh where was there was something else
wanted to
discuss was it again so here at 44 again
point of control right at the
bottom you know a ratio bounds low
indicating
some you know some stopping volume you
see the Delta change you know negative
negative negative positive positive
positive that that's a nice move and you
get a nice bounce up there so you know
really what I wanted to talk about is
you know watch for these points of
controls at the extremes of the bar at
the bottom of a green bar or at the top
of a red bar as it often indicates you
know some stopping volume in the market
that you know either support if it's on
a bottom of a green bar or
resistance if it's you know if it's at
the top of a of a red bar you as as a
Trader that's what you want to be
looking for you want to be looking for
these you know these Market generated
support and resistance
levels so you know thanks for watching
this video you subscribe to our YouTube
channel uh you know I try to put videos
out I've been a bit behind I've been a
bit sick for the last couple weeks but
uh I'm getting better and you know so
hopefully I'll be able to get some more
more videos I said you know this is not
a time of the year that that I'm trading
you know I I don't expect to trade but
you know I I do follow the markets I
obviously I keep my machines on and
um you know anything that's that's worth
worth pointing out I I'll point out to
you so you know really the the whole
lesson of of today's video was you know
points of controls at the bottom of
green bars or at the top of red bars and
you know if you get my software I I do
have something that will indicate it to
you but you know what if you're using
any other software go ladder knof
whatever that has a footprint chart you
should be able to see it um but but I
know if if you're watching many multiple
markets sometimes it's it's hard to keep
track of everything um you know I I
don't know how many different markets
each of you watch but I know I probably
watch about 20 and and different time
frames for some I say 20 at once but you
know it's like buns Dax Euro stocks in
the early morning then during Us hours
it's know e minis mini da crude oil it's
different things at different times of
the day so it's not like I'm staring at
20 different markets at once and I do
have multiple monitors so anyway you
know hopefully you got something of of
value out of this out of this video and
to learn more go to my website
orderflows dcom and thanks and I hope to
hear from you bye-bye